This is Jocko podcast number 10 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Oh,
salt into hell.
We waited a seeming eternity for the signal to start towards the beach.
The suspense was almost more than I could bear.
Weeding is a major part of war,
but I never experienced any more supreme Lee agonizing suspense in the
extrusion,
creating torture of those moments before we received the signal to begin the
assault on Pellalou.
I broke out in a cold sweat as the tension mounted with the intensity of the
bombardment.
My stomach was tied in knots.
I had a lump in my throat and swallowed only with great difficulty.
My knees nearly buckled,
so I Clung weekly to the side of the tractor.
I felt nauseated in feared that my bladder would surely empty itself and reveal
me to be the coward I was,
but the men around me look just about the same way I felt.
Finally,
with a sense of fatalistic relief mixed with a flash of anger at a navy officer
who was our wave commander.
I saw him waving his flag toward the beach are dry.
Our driver rev the engine,
the treads churned up the water and we started in the second wave is shore.
We moved ahead watching the frightful spectacle,
huge geysers of water rose around the amtraks ahead of us as they approached the
reef.
The beach was now marked along its length by a continuous sheet of flame backed
by a thick wall of smoke.
It seemed as though a huge volcano had erupted from the sea and rather than
heading for an island,
we were being drawn into the vortex of a flaming a bis.
For many,
it was to be oblivion.
Okay.
Suddenly a large shell exploded with a terrific concussion and a huge geyser are
up right next to our front.
It barely missed us.
The engine stalled the front of the tractor lurch to the left and bumped hard
against the rear of another ramp track that was either stalled or hit.
I never knew which.
We sat stalled floating in the water for some terrifying moments.
We were sitting ducks for the enemy gunners.
I look forward through their hatch behind the driver.
He was wrestling frantically with the control levers.
Japanese shells were screaming into the year and exploding all around us.
Sergeant Johnny Marr met,
leaned toward the driver and yelled something,
whatever it was.
It seemed to calm the driver because he got the engine started.
We moved forward again amid the geysers of exploding shells are bombardment,
began to lift off the beach and move inland.
Our dive bombers also moved inland with their strafing and bombing.
The Japanese increased their volume of fire against the waves of Amtrak's above
the din.
I could hear the ominous sound of shell fragments humming and grounding through
the air stand by someone yelled,
hit the beach Yeldon NCO moments before the machine lurch to a shop.
The men piled over the sides as fast as they could.
I followed Snafu,
climbed up and planted both feet firmly on the left side so as to leap as far
away from it as possible.
At that incident,
a burst of machine gun fire with white hot tracer snap through the air at eye
level,
almost grazing my face.
I pulled back like a turtle,
lost my balance and fell awkwardly forward down under the sand in a tangle of
ammo bag pack,
helmet,
car being gas,
mass,
cartridge belt and flopping canteens.
Get off the beach,
get off the beach,
race through my mind.
She else crashed all around fragments,
Tor and word slapping on the sand and splashing in the water a few yards behind
us.
The Japanese were recovering from the shock of our pre landing bombardment.
Their machine gun and rifle fire got thicker,
snapping viciously overhead in an increasing volume up and down the beach and
out on the reef.
A number of Amtrak's.
We're burning Japanese machine gun burst made long splashes on the water as
though flying it with some giant whip.
The geysers belched up relentlessly where the mortar and artillery shells hit.
I caught a fleeting glimpse of a group of Marines leaving a smoking Amtrak on
the reef.
Some fell as bullets and fragments splashed among them are buddies,
tried to help them as they struggled in knee deep water.
I shuttered and choked a while.
Desperate feeling of anger,
frustration,
and PD gripped me.
It was an emotion that would always torture my mind when I saw men trapped and
was unable to do anything but watch as they were,
hit my own plight,
forgotten momentarily.
I felt sick into the depths of my soul.
I ask God,
why,
why?
I turned my face away and wish that I were imagining it at all.
I tasted the bitterest essence of war,
the site of helpless comrades being slaughtered,
and it filled me with disgust.
That right there is
from a book,
an absolutely incredible book called with the old breed by Eugene sledge.
Okay.
Eugene sledge was a
marine.
He was a marine in World II and he ended up being a university professor and an
author.
When he got done,
he wrote this book.
I read this book for the first time when I was on deployment to Iraq,
my first deployment to Iraq.
And it,
it definitely,
it definitely kept me in check
because it,
it made me always remember that what we were experiencing this,
this war that we were in was
something that men had always experienced.
And actually they have experienced much,
much worse than I ever experienced.
And this book was later used to make the documentary a PBS documentary called
the war.
And in 2000,
I think it came out in 2010 was the Hbo Mini Series called the Pacific,
which is just an absolutely epic,
epic series.
And if you haven't watched the Pacific,
it's,
it's phenomenal.
Get it and watch it.
It's completely realistic.
One of the things that struck me when I watched it for the first time was,
you know,
he talks about the waiting and the very first episode of the Pacific,
you,
you're waiting for something happened.
They're showing the guys prep and then they actually land in n you'll waiting
in,
waiting for something to happen.
And it,
and it doesn't end.
It has this,
uh,
this feeling.
And I remember that feeling,
especially being in Ramadi when you'd be out in the streets and no shooting and
started yet.
And I would be,
you know,
everyone would have this feeling,
you waiting for it to start in every step.
You're waiting for it to start.
So it does a very,
a very,
it doesn't incredible job of portraying that and giving you that feeling.
Now what's important to remember about Eugene Sledge and,
and that's another great thing about the,
the,
the Pacific is that they do interviews with these guys.
They do interviews with them.
And you can see when you watch this,
you will see that Eugene sledge.
And as I thought about how I would describe Eugene Sledge,
he's,
yes,
he's a marine and you,
you know,
you get whatever ideas you get in your mind of what a Marine is.
You know,
a tough guy,
a,
a brief,
a guy filled with bravado.
Eugene sledge just will destroy that image because Eugene Sledge and,
and if,
if I think of the way I would describe him,
it would be to simply,
he's a good man.
And you can tell when he talks that he's an upright man and that he's a moral
man and he's a gentle in a kind person.
I mean it is his gentleness and his kindness oozes out of him.
And He seems like,
and I don't use this word very often,
but I will use it because this is how I would describe it.
He seems like a lovely human being.
I mean,
he just seems like a lovely person.
Hmm.
And so as we go into this book,
remember that this guy who went through this was just an absolutely incredibly
good
human
and also an incredible warrior.
Now,
the last podcast we talked about Patton and war as I knew it.
And that is a general's view.
And if you remember when we talked about when we went to Sri Lanka,
that was that that guy describe the,
the foot soldiers view as being a worm's view because you're so in the front
line that it's like a worm.
And that's what this is.
This is a soldier's book.
This is the troopers book.
This is the absolute front lines.
And it is a book that really unveils a lot about will and survival and the
psychological nature of war and what it does to people
and what people are capable of doing.
And also I think it makes it very clear why we fight against evil.
And I think that
it's something that makes me think always about where we are in the world
in a,
in a war
against evil.
So going back to the book,
we started to move inland.
We had gone only a few yards when an enemy machine gun opened up from a scrub
thicket to our right Japanese 81 millimeter in 90 millimeter mortars then opened
up on us.
Everyone hit the deck.
I dove into a shallow crater.
The company was completely pinned down.
All movements ceased.
The shells fell faster until I couldn't make out individual explosions.
Just continuous crashing rumbles with an occasional ripping sound of shrapnel
tearing low through the air overhead a month the roar,
the air was murky with smoking dust.
Every muscle
in my body was as tight as a piano wire.
I shuttered and shook as though we're having a mile.
Mild convulsion.
Sweat flowed profusely.
I prayed,
clenched my teeth,
squeezed my car,
buying stock and curse.
The Japanese are lieutenant,
a Cape,
a Cape Gloucester veteran who was nearby seem to be in about the same shape from
the meager protection of my shallow crater.
I pitied him or anyone out on that flat coral.
The heavy mortar barrage went on without slacking.
I thought it would never stop.
I was terrified by the big shells arching down all around us.
One was a bound to fall directly into my hole.
I thought if any orders were passed along or if anyone yelled for a corpsman,
I never heard it in all the noise.
It was as though I were out there on the battlefield all by myself,
utterly for Lorne and helpless in a tempest of violent explosions.
All any men could do was sweated out and pray for survival.
They would have been sure suicide to stand up in that firestorm
under my first barrage.
Since the fast moving events of hitting the beach,
I learned a new sensation,
other and absolute helplessness.
The shelling lifted in about a half an hour,
although it seemed to me to have crashed on for hours,
time had no meaning.
This was particularly true when under heavy shelling I could never judge how
long it lasted.
Orders then came to move up,
move out and I got up covered by a layer of coral dust.
I felt like jelly and couldn't believe any of us had survived that barrage.
So that feeling of helplessness and that is something that is,
is the w is one of the worst things for huge.
It's one of the worst human emotions,
right?
Helplessness.
And
I have,
I've,
I've experienced just a minor amount of shelling of being mortared and it is
definitely,
I was in a is in Iraq and my first deployment and we were on a fire base and we
were trying to help with some sniper Overwatch because this place had been being
attacked.
And we,
you know,
we,
this was early,
this is early in my first deployment.
My first time going to war and you know,
we're thinking,
Hey,
these guys are getting mortared.
Cool.
We'll go out there and just kill these people that are more room and we're,
we'll take care of it.
So we went out to this base on the outskirts of Baghdad and
sure enough,
we started getting mortared and the God,
the insurgents that were firing the mortars and knew exactly what they were
doing.
And it was,
it was horrible because it was in the city.
And so the mortars were being shot at us from three or 400 meters away,
but they were from behind the buildings and we could actually,
we could actually hear the mortars being launched.
So you would hear the home,
you'd hear the noise,
and you could actually see the fire trail of the launch.
So you knew.
So now there you are and you're sitting there and you,
you're just waiting to get to get blown up.
And it was,
it's interesting because if you have overhead cover,
which means if you have some kind of a strong roof over your head,
if you're inside of a building,
a strong building that's made of concrete,
it doesn't have to be a bunk or anything for,
for smaller mortars,
you're basically safe.
You know,
you're,
you're fine.
And we didn't really understand that yet.
So we had guys,
myself included,
that were exposed,
that were outside,
that were on rooftops.
And this is again,
I want to emphasize,
this is nothing,
this is nothing compared to what Eugene Sledge's talking about.
The only reason I'm bringing up is because I did experience it.
And my point is that even through one night where we took maybe,
I dunno,
maybe 10 mortar rounds in a night,
it actually affected the guys a little bit.
One night,
one night and you could see it actually when we got back to our compound,
we had a door on our tactical operation center that was a old piece of plywood
and it,
somebody had mounted a spring on there to keep it shut because it was hot and it
was air conditioning in there.
And it was a,
I was a strong spring.
And so when you walked out and you let that go,
it would slap and it would make a very loud bang.
And I literally,
after one measly night of getting mortared,
I watched guys shutter and at this flap of that noise.
And so to imagine what it was like for these guys for,
you know,
a half an hour of continuous shelling is,
it's just,
it's unbelievable.
And I'll tell you something else.
If you go back further than that,
and you go to world war one where those soldiers were in the trenches and they
got bombarded for months,
and if you want to know what that does to a human,
go on to youtube and Google World War One or going to youtube and search world
war one shell shock.
And it is horrendous to see the psychological damage that it did to these guys.
And the worst part of it was was that today we understand that we understand
what it does to people psychologically and we understand that it's,
it's,
it's a psychological damage.
And in World War One,
they didn't know that.
So these guys that broke,
they were cowards,
they were called cowards.
And to think about that is sickening to me knowing that my guys,
after like I said,
a minuscule amount of receiving mortar and artillery fire is mortar fire.
But it's the same thing.
It's indirect fire that didn't know that that already had a little bit of effect
to imagine.
What that did over time was,
was crazy.
And I was,
I got,
I got two moments in time that I remember that the,
that I had the feeling of helplessness we were on,
I was on the rooftop and again this was in Baghdad and we'd gone to the space to
set up some sniper positions and help them eliminate their problem.
Boy were we wrong.
So this rooftop was kind of divided up by concrete walls.
And to get to this,
to the furthest part away on the roof,
you had to go jump a bunch of these walls and you,
you know,
you were traveling probably,
I dunno,
50 meters across this rooftop to get to one of the corners.
And so I had,
you know,
I was checking the positions of all the guys and walking from position to
position to see where they are and see what their field of fire was and make any
adjustments if needed,
check in with them,
et cetera.
So I get up to this,
I climb out,
get on the roof,
climb up this,
climb up the stairs to the roof,
jump a bunch of these,
you know,
little four foot walls.
Just kind of getting over him takes two or three minutes to get,
and I finally get to this position where there's a,
one of the,
one of the gunners is sitting there and as I get there,
hey,
how's it going?
What are you seeing?
We're having our little discussion and all of a sudden we hear the mortar launch
shoom shoom and one of the other guys in the platoon gets on the radio and he
says,
uh,
he says,
that's three boys.
Count them out,
meaning okay,
there's going to be three booms.
And again,
we have no overhead cover cause I'm on the roof.
And I look at,
I look at the guy I'm with and he says,
you think we can make it back inside because you have time.
You know the,
the,
the mortar rounds going way up in the air.
He says,
do you think we can make it back inside?
And I said,
nope.
Then he says,
what should we do?
And I said,
hope it doesn't land in our quadrant,
meaning this little area that we actually the land in there,
we'd be dead.
But that's the feeling of helping us,
that,
that you have.
And,
and luckily that didn't land in our quadrant.
I was in another situation,
this was now on the,
on the Baghdad International Airport where our base was.
And there was an attack on,
on one of the gates.
And we went there as a quick reaction force and we get out there and as the
attacks happening and we're kind of showing up to see what we can do to help out
all of a sudden mortar start coming in.
And again,
I get down behind a,
just a normal,
like a Jersey barrier,
a concrete jersey barrier.
And,
but we're in a pretty open area other than this jersey barrier.
And again,
I'm,
I'm hunkered down with a one other seal and he looks at me and he goes,
what should we do?
And I go,
there's nothing we can do but sit here and suck it up.
And that's really all you can do.
And it's easy to look back and be like that.
That was funny,
you know,
but,
but that was,
that was,
uh,
three minutes of mortar bombardment,
right?
Yeah.
And,
and so just to imagine the psychological trauma that these guys experienced,
it was,
uh,
it was just,
it's,
it's horrible to imagine.
And the key point of all this,
I think,
is to think about as,
as it pertains to people as it pertains to individuals as it pertains to us now
to people in the civilian world,
what causes this intense anxiety and fear is the complete lack of control.
That's what causes it.
See,
when you're in a firefight or you're getting shot at,
it's coming from somewhere and you can hide from it and you can get down and you
can maneuver on it.
When it's,
when it's not that,
when it's just random death that you cannot control,
it's,
it's psychologically much,
much harder to deal with.
And thank God we didn't have to deal with it very often.
Now again,
when we were in Ramadi,
the guys that were over with the first of the five oh six on camp Corregidor,
those guys were getting mortared all the time.
I mean,
they were,
they were feeling it.
You don't get,
not as bad,
not world war one style,
but you know they were getting mortared every day.
There was mortars hit in the buildings.
So that,
that just randomness is what makes things so difficult.
He,
those mortars,
when you hear that first ignition of them,
how long does it take to,
it depends on how far away they were.
But you know,
in this it was probably like a minute,
maybe,
maybe a little less than that.
I'd have to sit here and think about it,
but it was like a minute,
maybe 30 seconds.
It might've been,
it might've been,
it might've been shorter than that,
but it seemed like a wall,
cause you're sitting there waiting for it to hit you.
And that was another eye on the one that was in Baghdad.
I was sitting there in a Humvee and we had this,
we had weapons on the Humvee that could reach across the river.
So we are by a river and we were looking at,
we could see some activity over across the river.
And so as we sat there are gunner,
I said,
hey,
can you see this?
And he's a guy,
I can,
I can kind of see it and I go,
do you have a shot?
And he goes,
no,
because we were behind a behind a bunk,
uh,
some kind of wall.
I go,
do you have a shot?
He goes,
no,
I can't.
I don't have a shot yet.
So I said,
hey,
pull the Humvee forward.
So I told the driver,
we pulled the Humvee for like,
I dunno,
30 feet,
maybe 35 feet and a minute later a mortar hit exactly where that only was.
Oh,
luckily it was only a 60 millimeter one,
which is a tiny little tiny little mortar and no one even got frack.
But I mean,
you know,
we were,
we were 30 seconds away or a minute away from just taking a mortar round right
in the Humvee that we were all in.
So yeah,
it's a,
it's
again,
I don't want to put anything that I experienced on any level with what these
guys experienced.
Yeah.
The only reason I'm saying is to give a miniscule psychological impact that it
has and just multiply that times a billion to get to where these guys were and,
and what they went through.
Yeah.
So going back to the book here,
after the fighting had kind of settled,
um,
sledge,
Eugene sledge comes across some dead Japanese soldiers.
So now they're kind of patrolling and there's some other veterans that were with
them and he standing there looking at these dead Japanese bodies and a guy comes
over and says,
sledgehammer,
don't stand there with your mouth open when there's all these good souvenirs
laying around.
So he sees these dead Japanese and he's going to get some war booty.
He then removed a Nambuu pistol,
slip the belt off the corpse and took the leather holster.
He pulled off the steel helmet,
reached inside and took out a neatly folded Japanese flag,
covered it with writing the veteran,
pitched the helmet on the coral where clanked and rattled,
rolled the corpse over and started pawing through the combat pack.
The veterans buddy came up and started stripping the other Japanese corpses.
His take was a flag and other items.
He then remove the bolts from the Japanese rifles and broke the stocks against
the coral to render them useless to infiltrators.
Yeah,
I hadn't budged or said a word just stood glued to the spot,
almost in a trance.
The corpses were sprawled where the veteran to drag them around to get into
their pacs and pockets.
Would I become this casual and Callista about enemy dead?
I wondered,
would the ward dehumanize me so that I too could field strip enemy dead with
such nonchalance?
The time soon came when it didn't bother me a bit.
I think again,
it's,
it's important to remember that this guy is a gentleman,
a kind soul and he knows and he's admitting that it came to a point where this,
this did not bother him at all.
Back to the book,
within a few yards of this scene,
one of our hospital corpsman worked in a small,
shallow,
deaf,
all defile,
treating marine wounded.
I went over and sat on the hot coral by him.
The corpsman was on his knees bending over to young marine who had just died.
On a stretcher.
A blood soaked battle dressing was on the side of the Marines of the dead man's
neck.
His fine,
handsome boy,
his face was Ashen.
What a pitiful waste.
I thought he can't be a day over 17 years old.
I thank God his mother couldn't see him.
The corpsman held the dead Marines Chin tenderly between the thumb and fingers
of his left hand left hand and made the sign of the cross with his right hand.
Tears streamed down his dusty tanned grief,
contorted face while he sobbed quietly.
Obviously again,
we have a vision in our mind of what,
uh,
service men is like,
what a marine is like.
And certainly that picture of um,
of a corpsman,
which is actually a navy corpsman.
If you don't know navy corpsman,
work with the Marines and go into the field with marines and train as Marines.
But you picture this navy corpsman in
trying to treat this man and losing him and out there in the middle of the bad
field battlefield with tears streaming down his face.
That's what combat is.
Moving to another section where you're about to see
some near friendly fire.
Here it is just then a marine tank took to our rear,
sorry,
just then a marine tank to our rear.
Must Miss Mistook us for enemy troops.
As soon as my hand went up to drop the round down the tube,
a machine gun cut loose.
It sounded like one of ours and from the rear of all places.
As I peeked over the edge of the crater through the dust and smoke and saw a
Sherman tank in the clearing behind us,
the tank fired it's 75 millimeter gun off to our right rear.
The shell exploded nearby around a bend in the same trail we were on.
I then heard the report of a Japanese field gun located there as it returned
fire on the tank.
Again,
I tried to fire but the machine gun opened up on us is before
a surge of panic rose within me.
In a brief moment,
our tank had reduced me to from a well trained determined assistant mortar
gunner to a quivering mass of terror.
It was not just that I was being fired at by a machine gun that unnerved me so
terribly,
but that it was one of ours to be killed by the enemy was bad enough.
That was a real possibility I prepared myself for but to be killed by mistake by
my own comrades was something I found hard to accept.
It was just too much and that is what we call a blue on blue when friendlies
shoot at friendlies and fratricide is when it's what it's called when brother
kills brother and you know this is actually the opening
of the book that Leif and I wrote extreme ownership.
The opening chapter is about this,
this happening and happening under my command to my guys when I'm the senior guy
and that's why this idea that to be killed by mistake by my own comrades was
something I found hard to accept.
This is the,
this is the mortal sin of combat in sometimes when I talk about my deployment to
Ramadi and what it was like for us,
I,
I say that basically every bad thing that could happen happened,
and this is definitely one of them,
is,
is being in a situation where there was friendly fire and we were in a number of
situations like this.
None of them were as bad as I as the first one I talk about in the book and
here's how these guys get it solved.
A volunteer crawled off to the left and soon the tank ceased firing on us.
We learned later that our tankers were firing on us because we had moved too far
ahead.
They thought we were enemy support for the field gun.
This also explained why the enemy's shelling was passing over an exploding
behind us.
Tragically,
the marine who saved us by identifying us to the tanker was shot off the tank
and killed by a sniper.
Definitely one of the worst things in war.
You think you have to worry about the enemy and things are so confusing and
there's such mayhem out there that you,
you have to spend at least as much time if not more deconflict thing with your
friendly troops as you do.
Trying to figure out where the enemy is and killed him.
It,
it's,
it was definitely a fast learning curve for us in Ramadi learning and
understanding and deconflict and wanting to be so absolutely certain of where
everybody was and the term we would use and is using the military as front line
trace.
Where are your guys?
Where's the most forward that they are?
And everybody needs to know that.
In fact,
and this might sound crazy,
so we'd have,
you know,
people have in their minds of um,
of a sniper position being,
you know,
two or three guys hidden very tactically and clandestine mine in Ramadi.
Sometimes for our sniper,
Overwatch positions.
First of all,
sometimes we have 20 or 30 guys in there to secure a building so that the
snipers and the machine gunners could work.
But on top of that,
in order to avoid there being a blue on blue,
we had giant aircraft marking panels.
So fluorescent orange,
10 by 10 pieces of material that we would literally,
the guys would literally hang them over the side of the Overwatch positions to
say,
here we are,
everyone don't shoot us.
Oh bad guys,
you want to shoot us,
bring it and we'll kill you.
But that's,
that's the extent that,
that we would go to to ensure that you weren't going to get shot by American
forces.
And there's,
you know,
life's got a,
uh,
a vignette in the book as well.
A story about that almost happening.
And I tell another one that blue on blue stuff was a nightmare.
It was a nightmare to deal with.
And you know,
one thing I will say is we had that horrible one that resulted in a,
in an Iraqi soldier killed,
a friendly Iraqi soldier killed very early on in our deployment.
But we learned so much from it that we,
we,
there was blue and blue's that happened after that.
But then we never had them get out of control like that first event.
But again,
for those people that have never been in combat before,
and it was weird when Lafe and I write in the book,
you know,
we got done,
I said,
man,
we've got three stories that are based on some sort of blue on blue happening.
And we didn't plan it that way.
But again,
just to realize,
you know,
that's,
that's how much we were thinking about it,
that when we wrote about it,
three of the stories were uh,
just about,
hey,
preventing blue on blues,
having a blue on blue and then two of them run by preventing blue on blues.
And if you've never been into combat,
you would,
you wouldn't think about that.
It's so confusing.
It's so confusing that there were situations in Ramadi where Humvees fired on
other humvees.
So,
so this is an American vehicle and it's not like the,
uh,
the insurgents had humvees.
I mean,
a Humvee is a very distinctive looking vehicle.
And there was situations where in the confusion and the mayhem and with you
know,
muzzle flashes,
Humvees shot at other humvees.
That's how,
that's how crazy and chaotic combat can get
back to the book.
Moving forward,
and this is going to go back into the shelling and I almost wasn't going to talk
about this,
but I had to.
There was nothing subtle or intimate about the approach and explosion of an
artillery shell.
When I heard the whistle of an approaching one in the distance,
every muscle in my body contracted,
I braced myself in a puny effort to keep from being swept away.
I felt utterly helpless as the fiendish whistle grew louder my teeth ground
against each other.
My heart pounded,
my mouth dried,
my eyes narrowed,
sweat poured over me.
My breath came in short,
irregular gasps and I was afraid to swallow lest I choke.
I always prayed sometimes out loud under certain conditions of range and
terrain,
I could hear the shell approaching from a considerable distance,
thus prolonging the suspense into seemingly unending torture.
At the instant,
the voice of the shell grew the loudest.
It terminated in a flash and a definitely explosion similar to the crash of a
loud clap of thunder.
The ground shook and the concussion hurt my ears.
Shell fragments tore through the air toward the air apart as they rushed out,
worrying and ripping rocks and dirt clattered onto the deck as as smoke of the
exploded shell dissipated.
And this is something I need to point out when you w w w when I,
when I,
before I was ever in combat and ever saw what mortars really did.
When you think of shrapnel,
when people think of shrapnel,
like,
like how big do you think of a piece of shrapnel list?
Just take a guess.
This big,
so echos,
action and a half,
two inches.
Hechos holding up an inch and a half,
I actually thought smaller than that.
I thought,
you know what?
It's a little tiny thing and you know,
you gotta be scared.
You got to watch out these little tiny things on bigger artillery shells or
mortar shells.
The F,
the frag that comes off of them is a half an inch thick and it can be nine
inches long by 12 inches long,
jagged shards of metal.
You know,
they're just evil thing.
And,
and,
and that's why what's scary is the shrapnel.
Oh yeah.
It can,
it can hit you in like puncture you like a bullet,
but it can also take your leg clean off or take your arm thing off for just,
just completely,
I mean,
just kill you instantly if it hits you in the torso.
But it's a,
it's a Blim remover.
So it's much more horrifying than,
than what I ever envisioned it to be.
And the reason that,
one of the reasons this sticks in my mind so well is getting mortared.
Uh,
we were at in combat outpost Falcon in downtown Ramadi and we took some hundred
and 20 millimeter mortar shells in there.
And we,
you know,
the company commander who is a awesome,
unbelievable guy,
he,
he brought in a piece of frack.
And the thing was,
I couldn't believe it when I saw that,
I was shocked at how huge it was.
Do you mean a piece of,
and like a random piece of piece of frag that had come in off the mortar shells
blew off and you know,
bounce down the street,
didn't hit anybody and he picked it up and brought it in and said here's what's
flying around the air wait till or these things that they load into the,
to the shell or the shell shell is the show is encased in metal and that's what
the metal is for.
That when it blows up,
it just rips apart and gets people.
Yeah.
You when like when you see on TV about these,
I don't know,
these criminals or whatever,
they said pipe bombs.
You put that up,
nails,
screws.
Yeah.
You'd think so.
This is like that times 10.
Yeah.
It's big and it's freaking horrifying.
Dang.
That's another one.
I remember one of those same situation,
we got hit with some mortars in Cop Falcon and Lafe and his,
his team were like 300 meters away on a rooftop of a building and frag landed on
them.
You know it,
it wasn't a,
it didn't have the philosophy to hurt anybody,
but it was raining down on them,
so it's probably all hot too.
Oh yeah.
It looks horrible.
Back to the book to be under a barrage of prolonged shelling simply magnified
all the terrible physical and emotional effects of one shell.
To me,
artillery was an invention of hell.
The onrushing whistle and scream of the big steel package of destruction was the
pinnacle of violent fury and the embodiment of pent up evil.
It was the essence of violence and of man's inhumanity to man.
I developed a passion,
a passionate hatred for shells to be killed by a bullet seemed so clear and
surgical,
but shells would not only and rip the body,
they tortured one's mind almost beyond the brink of sanity.
After each shell was wrung out,
after each shell,
I was rung out,
limp and exhausted.
During prolonged shelling,
I often had to restrain myself and fight back a wild,
inexorable urge to scream,
to sob and to cry as pell Lou dragged on.
I feared that if I ever lost control of myself under shell fire,
my mind would be shattered.
I hated shells as much for their damage to the mind as to the body to be under
heavy shell fire was to me by far the most terrifying combat experiences.
Each time it left me feeling more for Lauren and helpless,
more fatalistic and with less confidence that I could escape the dreadful law of
averages that reduced our numbers.
Fear is many faceted and has many sub subtle nuances,
but the terror and desperation and dirt under heavy shelling are by far the most
unbearable.
And I think
again,
the key point of that,
if you want to take something from that and apply it to life,
because most people that are listening to this podcast won't have to endure
showing other than those troopers that are out there on the front lines today.
God bless him.
Those guys are out there.
They may have to deal with us and they will.
But for civilians,
for normal people,
it's the feeling of helplessness.
It's the feeling of lack of control that makes it so horrifying.
And so when you come up against things that you cannot control,
that's something to recognize that it is something that you cannot control and
that's what's scaring you.
That's what the fear is coming from and making it infinitely worse than
something that you can control.
Yeah.
You know another thing that they had to help them deal with the fear was the
comradery
and he talks a little bit about this,
talking about his company.
I realized that company K we'll kilo,
I realized that company K had become my home.
No matter how bad a situation was in the company,
it was still home to me.
It was not just a lettered company in a number of battalion and a number of
regimen in a number of division.
It meant far more than that.
It was home.
It was my company.
I belonged in it and no else.
Most marines I knew felt the same about their companies and whatever battalion
regiment or Marine Division they happen to be in.
This was the result of,
or maybe a cause for our strong esprit de Corps.
The Marine Corps wisely acknowledged this unit attachment.
Men who recovered from wounds and return to duty nearly always came home to
their old company.
This was not misplaced sentimentality,
but a strong contributor to high morale.
A man felt that he belonged to his unit and had a niche among his buddies whom
he knew and with whom he shared a mutual respect welded in combat.
This sense of family.
It was particularly important in the infantry where survival and combat
efficiency often hinged on how well men could depend on one another,
a spree decor.
And now there's a section that I'm moving forward to and this section is called
the stench of battle.
The Sun board down on us like a giant heat lamp.
Occasional rains fell on the hawk.
Coral merely evaporated like steam off hot pavement.
The air hung heavy and muggy.
Everywhere we went on the ridges,
the hot humid air wheat with the stench of death,
a strong wind was no relief.
It simply brought the horde odor from an adjacent area.
Japanese corpses lay where they fell among the rocks and on the slopes.
It was impossible to cover them.
Usually there was no soil that could be spaded over them.
Just the hard jagged coil coral,
the enemy dead simply rotted where they had fallen.
They lay all over the place and grotesque positions with puffy faces and
grinning buck tooth expressions.
It was difficult to convey to anyone who is not experienced it.
The gas leak horror of having your sense of smell saturated constantly with the
putrid odor of rotting human flesh day after day,
night after night.
Yeah.
This was something that men have an infantry battalion got a horrifying dose of
during the long protracted battle such as Pella Pellalou in the tropics.
The dead became bloated and gave off a terrific stench within a few hours after
death.
Whenever possible.
We remember we removed marine dead to the rear of the company's position there.
They were usually laid on stretchers and covered with ponchos which stretched
over the head of the corpse down to the ankles.
I rarely saw dead marine left on covered with his face exposed to the sun,
rain and flies.
Somehow it seemed in decent not to cover our dead.
Often though the dead might lie on the stretchers for some time and decompose
badly before the breeze.
Busy grave registration crews could take them for burial in the division
cemetery near the airfield
added to the awful stench of the dead of both sides was the repulsive odor of
human excrement everywhere.
It was all but impossible to practice.
Simple elemental field sanitation on most areas of Palu because of the rocky
surface field.
Sanitation during maneuvers and combat was the responsibility of each man.
In short,
under normal conditions,
he covered his own waste with a scoop of soil at night.
When he didn't dare venture out of his foxhole,
he simply used to empty grenade canister or ration cans and threw it out of his
hole and scooped out dirt over it the next day.
If he wasn't under enemy fire,
that was not possible.
On Pellalou.
Yeah,
added to this was the older of thousands of rotting discarded Japanese and
American rations at every breath.
One inhaled humid air heavy with countless repulsive odors.
I felt as though my lungs would never be cleansed of these foul vapors.
As I looked on at the stains on the coral,
I recalled some of the eloquent phrases of politicians and newsmen about how
gallant it was for a man to shed his blood for his country and to give life's
blood for sacrifice and so on.
The word seemed so ridiculous.
Only the flies benefited.
So as patriotic
and brave
as Eugene sludge was
the madness,
the madness even made him begin to question what this was all about and think
about what these politicians would say
and say that only the flies benefited.
Hmm.
It's crazy how he went so detailed in the,
in the smells,
because you know,
when you watch movies and that's a part that you don't,
don't catch on it every once in a while or the,
you know,
the guy he's covering his nose or something like that to indicate this smells
bad,
but that doesn't stick in your mind the whole time.
Maybe if they add like flies or something.
I Dunno.
Um,
but how he,
how he illustrated how this was going on to the point where I had never even
thought I'd ever catch
a fresh breath.
You know,
basically this is going to stay.
And it really adds that element of,
of hell,
you know,
and they say that smell is one of the most like impactful senses.
You have beckon,
beckon,
like spark memories the strongest,
you know,
no doubt about it.
And there's,
there is a smell.
There was a smell in Iraq.
Obviously it wasn't as bad as this,
but it was,
it's,
it's a,
it's a bad smell.
Yeah.
And for sure when something hits me,
if you're an a,
you know,
a strange place or a place where there's that,
where it's not sanitary,
you can get that momentary remembrance of that smell.
And this section called the stench of combat is beyond just the smell,
which we'll get into now.
The grinding stress of prolonged heavy combat,
the loss of sleep because of night,
nightly infiltration rates.
The vigorous physical demands forced on us by the rugged terrain and the
unrelenting suffocating heat were enough to make us drop in our tracks.
How we kept going and continue fighting.
I'll never know.
I was so indescribably weary physically and emotionally that I became fatalistic
praying only for my fate to be painless,
thinking he's going to die and his only prayer is that it's painless that's
straight up,
believed in it like you know you're going to die.
In addition to the terror and hardships of combat each day brought some new
dimension of dread for me.
I witnessed some new ghastly McRob facet in the kaleidoscope of the unreal as
though designed by some fiendish ghoul to cause even the most hardened and
callused observer among us to recoil in horror and disbelief.
Late one afternoon,
a buddy and I returned from the gun pit in the fading light,
we passed a shallow deaf laid we hadn't noticed previously in it were three
marine dead.
They were lying on stretchers where they had died before their comrades had been
forced to withdraw.
Sometime earlier.
As we move past,
my buddy groaned Jesus.
I took a quick glance into the depression and recoiled and revulsion and pity at
what I saw.
The bodies were so badly decomposed and nearly blackened by exposure.
This was to be expected of the dead in the tropics,
but these marines had been mutilated hideously by the enemy.
One man had been decapitated his head,
lay on his chest,
his had been severed from his wrists,
and also lay on his chest near his chin in disbelief.
I stared at the face as I realized that the Japanese had cut off the dead
marines penis and stuffed it into his mouth.
The corpse next to him had been treated similarly.
The third had been butchered,
chopped up like a carcass torn apart by some predatory animal.
My emotions solidified into rage and a hatred for the Japanese beyond anything
I'd ever experienced.
From that moment on,
I never felt the least pity or compassion for them.
No matter what the circumstances.
My comrades would field strip their packs and pockets for souvenirs and take
gold teeth,
but I never saw a marine commit that kind of barbaric mutilation that the
Japanese committed if they had access to are dead.
Like I said,
it's a glimpse into
the darkest
part of humanity.
And
I want people to think about that and remember that it's real.
It's real,
that dark part of humanity that
we don't want to exist.
It exists.
Evil exists.
And this is coming from a guy,
you know when he says that he never had any pity
after this again,
and you,
if you go and watch the Pacific and you watch interviews with this guy,
you can absolutely feel like I said,
the,
the kindness oozes out of him.
But even he,
when confronting the darkness,
had to
explore his own darkness.
And I'm jumping now
to the end.
On August 8th we heard that the first atomic bomb had been dropped on Japan,
reports a bound for a week about a possible surrender.
Then on 15 August,
1945 the war ended.
We received news with quiet disbelief coupled with an indescribable sense of
relief.
We thought the Japanese would surrender.
Many refuse to believe it.
Sitting in stunned silence we remembered are dead.
So many dead.
So many maimed,
so many bright futures consigned to the ashes of the past.
So many dreams lost in the madness that had engulfed us.
Okay.
Except for a few widely scattered shouts of joy.
The survivors of the abyss sat hollow,
wide and silent,
trying to comprehend a world without war.
War is brutish in glorious and a terrible waste.
Combat leaves an indelible mark on those who are forced to endure it.
The only redeeming factors where my comrades incredible bravery and their
devotion to each other.
Okay.
Marine Corps Training Thomas to kill efficiently and to try to survive,
but it also taught us loyalty to each other and love that a spree decor
sustained us
until the millennium arrives and country sees trying to enslave others.
It will be necessary to accept one's responsibilities and be willing to make
sacrifices for one's countries.
As my comrades did,
as the troops used to say,
if the country is good enough to live in,
it's good enough to fight for
with privilege goes responsibility
and that
is another look
at war
and
it's something that we can't ever forget.
That war is awful in that war is the darkness that I talk about.
And
as Eugene Sledge says,
the only redeeming factor
is the incredible bravery and devotion to each other.
And I've talked about that before.
What made
war to me
an incredibly life altering experience.
It wasn't the darkness that I saw,
but the light of the bravery
of those on the battlefield.
And I will add another redeeming quality to war.
And it's a,
and that is what is the alternative.
So what if we had not stopped the brutal imperial Japanese empire?
What if we had not stopped the Nazis?
What if we had not fought a war against ourselves to end slavery?
And today
they're still evil in the world.
They're still darkness.
Isis,
the cult of child rapists and see this and torturers and murderers.
And if we don't confront that evil
and that evil goes unchecked,
then darkness prevails.
So we have to be a force of light against the darkness.
And
as Eugene Sledge transformed partially in his brain,
we have to use the darkness and the evil ourselves to prevail.
That's the paradox.
And we have to remember that when men get so close to evil,
it leaves a mark and it leaves a scar
and we must forgive them their trespasses and help them to heal if they need it.
So to the men and women who are fighting or who have fought against forces of
evil in the world.
Thank you.
If we were going to
dive into that to apply or think about that in context of
normal people,
I would say just remember how horrible things can be
and and enjoy that sunrise in the morning.
Again,
that book is called with the old breed by Eugene sledge and I hit some
highlights but the entire book is incredible.
The Hbo Mini Series is called the Pacific.
Watch it.
It's incredible
and remember,
remember,
remember.
All
right,
let's get to
some questions,
some questions from the interwebs.
Yes,
Internet questions.
Okay.
And by the way,
is a bit late in the game but good evening Echo Charles.
Good evening and thanks for joining.
Thank a lot of start chiming in.
Get
with with a book like this.
I mean,
I'm coming over here to the studio and it is in my mind.
I am,
I'm fired up and,
and I picture when I want to listen to a podcast,
I want to sit down,
I want to pray,
I'm going to put the headphones on,
I want to press play and I want to get it.
I want to get after it.
I want something to get in my brain and start to make me think.
And uh,
that's where I was tonight.
When I got on on track,
I said,
hey,
this is the,
this is the podcast and here we go.
And I just went into it.
Yeah,
no,
it was,
there was no echo Charles in my brain at that note.
No offense.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want to be in your brain bread.
Do you think I like to listen anyway?
I just don't know when the timing,
in fact,
I do know when to chime in when I have a question.
That's it.
That's true.
There's no reason.
So no one wants to hear you say,
hey,
Eco,
hello,
how's it going?
Or nothing like that.
It cut out
the small talk and let's get down to business.
We can small talk now.
Now that I've released the,
the passion that I had and I was at brewing up in my brain can remember I'm
prepping these things.
So I'm going through this book for for a week or two and I'm delving into it and
I'm doing other,
I'm watching youtube videos of the Pella Lou battle.
It's in my brain and it's wanting to get,
it's wanting to come out.
So you just get trumped by that.
No offense,
nope,
none taken.
All right.
Questions Jocko.
How do you balance extreme ownership with holding others accountable for their
actions and avoiding them using you?
So this is actually a question that I ended up responding to on a fairly regular
basis and it's really a couple of different angles here that are going on.
The one of the,
the points here is the balance of extreme ownership versus holding others
accountable and what that really means or what another way of looking at that as
it's really extreme ownership versus decentralized command.
So decentralized command is,
it's one of the laws of combat that wave and I write about in the book
decentralized command.
And what that means is everybody leads.
That means everybody's a leader and that's what you want.
And that is uh,
that is a,
the complete opposite of extreme ownership.
So if extreme ownership,
I'm going to own everything.
Decentralized Command is,
I'm going to let everyone else lead.
So there's a real,
a real contradiction,
a real dichotomy there.
So what you have to do is balance it.
You have to balance.
And it's the only way to,
to sort of rectify or re or reconcile those two opposing forces.
Because you do,
you do have to have extreme ownership of everything that is true.
And at the same time,
you have to have decentralized command to,
because you can't be everywhere at once and you have to let your frontline
leaders lead.
So you have to balance them.
So that's one part of it is that you should,
if you feel yourself,
for instance,
if you feel like you can't get everything done and you're,
you're losing control or your,
you're not able to execute everything cause there's too much on your plate,
it means that you're not delegating enough.
It means that you're not,
your frontline troopers aren't stepping up and leading now.
So you've gone too far in one direction.
Now if your leaders,
or if all of a sudden you're having to tell your leaders like,
hey,
you need to get this done.
Hey,
what are you doing?
Why aren't you taking initiative?
Then that means you've gone too far in the other direction.
So you have to find the good balance.
And that's the,
that's the goal.
And again,
and I'll say it over and over again,
that's what makes leadership hard leadership.
The hardest thing about leadership is that there's opposing forces that you have
to balance.
And if you could just pick the extreme and go with it,
and that made you a good leader,
anyone could do it.
But it's not.
It's it's the balance that makes you a good leader.
It's the balance that's challenging.
So now the other word,
so that's part of the question.
The other word
is accountability and holding people accountable for their actions.
Now this is where I'm going to throw something out that people are not going to
expect me to say because people always talk about accountability and I hear that
all the time in businesses and they say,
yeah,
we really need accountability,
accountability,
accountability and years.
The issue I have with that,
you don't want to have to rely on accountability.
Accountability is actually a crutch.
It's a tool,
and I'm not saying you never use it because sometimes you do have to use it.
You have to implement it.
If people aren't doing what they're supposed to do,
you have to hold them accountable,
but I will tell you this,
what you,
what you don't want is people that are doing their job only because you're
holding them accountable.
That's not what you want.
You want people that take initiative and ownership of their job and they do it
not because you want them to or because you're going to inspect them.
They do it because they own it.
They take extreme ownership of it.
That's what you want.
So if you were to ask people that work for me,
if I held them accountable and they would be like,
mm,
not really.
I mean,
for instance,
weapons inspections.
So you know,
I'm in charge of a platoon or I'm in charge of a task unit and there's a couple
of hundred weapons or whatever,
a bunch of weapons.
And if you don't take care of those weapons and people don't maintain them and
clean them and
lubricate them properly,
they can rust very easily.
And so we know one of the things that you may have to do is do weapons
inspections to make sure that my guys are cleaning their weapons.
And I can tell you,
I rarely if ever conducted actual weapons inspections.
The reason my guys,
my guys did it,
my guys owned it.
My guys wanted to be the best.
They wanted to always have the best possible reputation.
And so I didn't have to go around inspecting their weapons because I knew that
they were going to do it.
I knew that that my guys who were on board,
who understood why we were doing what we were doing,
who understood that we wanted to be the best and who were on board with trying
to be the best said,
you know what you,
you know,
we are going to make sure these weapons are the best possible.
And I learned this when I was in my second platoon.
My boss was an awesome guy and this is a guy that I've talked about before.
He was a huge influence on me.
He was a,
a prior enlisted seal who became an officer.
He was a combat veteran from the Warner Granada and he was a very humble guy and
he's actually the guy that inspired me to become an officer because I said to
myself,
wow,
this guy is,
this guy made our lives so good.
Maybe I could do that for 16 guys in a platoon someday.
But what I realize about him is he never held us accountable for anything.
But at the same time he infused accountability on us because what we wanted more
than anything else was to do a good job for him and for the platoon.
That's,
that's how you get troops and teams are aligned,
not by holding them accountable with imposed accountability,
but where they are inspired themselves to hold themselves accountable.
I knew I had a coaching call with a team the other day that was,
they were saying,
hey,
you know,
we really,
we would like to have you,
you know,
coach us because we're,
we're lacking in these areas and we really need,
we know what to do,
but we really need someone to hold us accountable to do it.
And I was like,
listen,
I,
I charge a lot of money and you guys would be stupid to give it to me.
You guys just simply lack the discipline to work for the team and make it
happen.
I,
and I threw this example.
I said,
you know,
if you are competing against another team,
and what I did was I moved into your house and I woke you up in the morning and
I held you accountable for what you're supposed to do and I made you do it.
So we put the ultimate and accountability on top of them.
I said,
who would do better?
You guys with me waking you up in the morning and beating you until you
accomplish what you were supposed to do.
I'd held you to the up the highest standard of accountability or a team that was
hungry themselves that was going to go the extra mile that was going to do more
work.
It was going to stay up later.
That was going to get up earlier.
Not because somebody was holding them accountable,
but because they had the desire for victory.
Who's going to win that contest?
And the answer is very simple.
Those with the innate and intrinsic desire to win,
we'll win over those that have imposed discipline and accountability put on top
of them now because there's a dichotomy to everything.
And because there's a balanced everything,
there are times where in a leadership position you do need to inspect and make
sure that you hold people accountable.
And an example I have of that is we had,
when we got to Ramadi,
we had our radios and generally the radio men knew how to program the radios
and,
and get them sinked up so they could talk to other radios and all that.
And I told the guys,
I'm like,
listen,
everybody in the troop needs to know how to program your radio yourself.
And everyone says,
oh,
okay.
And
it was so critical that they know how to program these radios.
Because if you're out in the field and you get separated from your unit and all
of a sudden your radio gets zero wised or it has a problem and you don't know
how to fix it yourself,
what are you going to do?
You can't talk to anybody and you're doomed,
you're gonna die.
So because it was that critical.
I actually,
after the first briefing,
I called a couple of guys up and I said,
give me a radio and I zero wise their radios.
And I said,
okay,
reprogram it now.
And a couple of them didn't know how to do it and I said,
okay,
listen up guys.
No one is going on operation if you can't reprogram your radio.
And so the guys had to sit down and go and figure out how to do it.
So there's times where you,
you do have to hold people accountable.
And in that situation I knew that even though I was saying,
hey,
it's important,
they didn't realize how important it was because you know,
it was all,
you got gotta know how to work your gear.
They kind of took it like that.
I knew that guys didn't really understand the nature of how important it was to
be able to operate and reprogram your entire radio and sync it with the army
radios and all that.
I knew that they didn't quite understand how important it was and so I had to,
I had to hold them accountable.
But generally 98% of the stuff,
I didn't have to hold people accountable.
I didn't inspect things.
I expected things and they delivered
and,
and that's,
that's,
people will follow your lead if you take ownership.
That's how my guys have always been.
They've always
the scene that Anne and known what the expectations were.
And finally,
if,
if you're sitting there and you keep saying to yourself,
I got to hold people accountable,
I got to hold people accountable.
Most likely you don't need to hold them accountable.
You need to lead them.
You need to make them understand why they're doing what they're doing,
why it's important,
how it impacts the strategic mission,
how it impacts the team,
how it impacts them.
That's leadership,
not accountability.
It's leadership.
Accountability is just a tool and it is a,
uh,
a,
it's a crude tool compared to real leadership.
So use it if you have to,
but try and use leadership instead.
Next question.
Jocko.
I'm entering the police academy in a few short weeks,
then I'll be a police officer after six months.
I have no military background and have very little experience with true
confrontation.
And violence.
What are the best ways a police officer can condition themselves to violence and
confrontation?
I currently train Jujitsu,
but I'm not.
I am,
but I am curious what else I can do to keep myself and others safe from
unpredictable violence.
This is not a self defense question or either mental conditioning question.
Very cool question.
Uh,
appreciate that question because this individual recognizes that there's a
little bit more to it than just the physical self defense then that's the mental
and he's 100% right.
So here's some things that you can do
when you get the opportunity.
You got to get some realistic training going.
And I've talked about it a little bit on with a kind
of realistic training that we did in the seal teams.
There's things that up the intensity greatly simunition or uh,
like a paint ball scenario.
Another good thing is getting,
uh,
you know,
really heavy sparring equipment on.
So face gear,
you know,
and really go to town.
We are trying to attack someone and take them down and do it,
you know,
three on one,
four on one.
Got To be careful not to get hurt.
You don't want to go that extreme.
But if someone puts on head gear,
you know,
with a face mask and the whole nine yards,
shin guards in padded outfit on and people can attack them and you have to react
to it.
The other good thing to do is do it in a situation where you know,
you don't let the guy know what's going to happen.
You know he's gotta keep his eyes closed until you say go.
When he opens his eyes,
there's someone there with a knife right in front of a fake knife,
right in front of him is going to stab him and he's got to draw his weapon and
shoot or defend himself somehow.
So you want to hit him with these unexpected drills,
with your weapons,
without your weapons shooting and moving.
So those are,
those are the kinds of things.
As soon as you get the opportunity to do it and it's even good.
I mean,
if you've been in a,
in a,
you know,
shooting drill with like a barricaded shooter,
which is,
you know,
you put a shooter at the end of a hallway and he's hidden,
but he's shooting at you with paint ball and you get,
you can get the intensity up very high.
It's getting shot with paint ball hurts.
And if you're getting nailed and you got to do something and people are like,
hey,
you gotta make a call,
go do something.
You've got to make it happen.
How are you gonna stop this guy?
You can get your intensity up and you can get used to that.
You can inoculate yourself somewhat to that stress and learn to detach yourself
from it and not let it affect you and not let it grind on you.
So that's the realistic training.
And,
and honestly,
I,
when I watch some of the police videos of the bad shootings,
now we know police officers throughout the country every day are under a burden
of hostility and they do an outstanding job over and over again making great
arrests and helping people and saving people that are suicidal,
incredible amount of things,
right?
Of course,
no one releases those videos and they don't go viral.
The videos that go viral and the videos that people watch are the good ones,
the bad ones,
the bad ones.
And I hope that the police departments across America are doing something to
inoculate their troopers from the stress cause that when I watched these videos,
that is what I see happening.
The,
the stress level and the,
the inexperience of the situation.
And there's one video that I watched which is awful,
and the guy gets a call,
uh,
you see as you see his,
the first thing you see it,
the whole thing is a body camera.
And forgive me if someone pulls this video up and I'm not a hundred percent
accurate,
but he gets a call.
It's at a seven 11 guy with a gun guy pulls a new seven 11 the cop pulls into
the seven 11 as he's getting,
he gets out of his car and he sees a guy kind of walk in one direction out of
the seven 11 and turn and walk in another direction.
Guys got a Hoodie on.
He's walking away so the cop gets out.
He's yelling at him,
Hey,
stop,
stop.
That guy doesn't stop.
Finally he's,
he's now approaching him and he's standing in the open,
and this is something that I see in a lot of these videos.
These cops,
they stand in the open when,
if you imagine that the other guy has a gun to,
why would you stand in the open,
take cover,
you take cover.
That's the first thing you do.
If you're,
even if you're trying to stop somebody or trying to yell at someone,
you take cover.
So if they turn around and to have a gun,
you only have a small portion of your body exposed and you don't get scared
because you're hanging out in the open.
So,
so anyways,
this guy is approaching,
he's standing out in the open,
he's yelling at the guy.
Finally the guy turns around and when the guy turns around,
he reaches in his jacket and boom,
the cop shoots him,
the guy falls down,
he kind of rolls into a curb,
the cop comes over.
As soon as the cop comes over,
you very quickly realize what's going on.
And that is that the guy had headphones on underneath his hoodie and he couldn't
hear the copy yelling at them.
And then as the cop searches him,
he pulls out of his pocket,
his iPhone.
And so he was just listening to music,
reached in his pocket to uh,
turn it off,
and he got shot.
Horrible situation.
So how do you inoculate yourself to that?
You've got to put yourself into training situations where you do have the
instinct to take cover,
where you do have the instinct to see what people's hands are.
We do have the instinct to realize that you put yourself in a better situation
where if the guy does pull out a gun,
you have time to react to it and you can react to it from a safer distance,
you know,
as a,
so there's a lot of things I would love to start to,
and I don't know how,
you know,
I don't know how I'm,
I don't know how to go about this,
but I would love to start working with police departments in some manner to get
some training set up.
Like the training we had in the seal teams,
which was the training that I sit up in the seal teams was psychotic.
How stressful we would make it so that these guys were overwhelmed.
They were as explosions,
machine,
gun,
fire,
paint balls,
hitting them,
um,
uh,
smoke everywhere,
screaming,
civilians,
screaming wounded,
uh,
actors.
We'd hire actors that were amputees and they have spurting all the
places.
It was incredibly realistic.
And that way when guys got into combat,
like one of the first time I ever got shot on it,
I was like,
okay,
here's what's going on.
So I hope at some point I can,
I can help the military with that.
Now in addition to that,
as you're trying to knock yourself your to this violence and get used to this,
watch those youtube videos,
watch those youtube videos of street fights of stupid encounters with,
with bars,
with drunk people and bouncers with uh,
the shoot or don't shoot scenarios with cops,
military situations where they have helmet cams on and you can see things
happening.
And what you want to do is you want to watch those videos and you want to pay
attention to the people,
to the humans and watch the reactions and watch their movements and watch their
body language and watch their expressions on their faces and see and judge and
predict and go to another video and hit pause and say,
this is what I see right here.
This is what I think is about to happen.
And educate yourself on human nature because human nature is what you're going
to be dealing with.
And violence is a part of human nature.
And sometimes things go violent and sometimes they don't.
So how do you predict that?
And if you're unsure,
which you will be,
how do you protect yourself first and give yourself the maximum amount of time
to make a judgment call so you don't have to rush
on top of that.
It's awesome that you're doing Jujitsu,
do boxing,
do Moitai do wrestling.
So you get used to getting hit.
So you start to see what a person's face looks like when they're about to hit
you.
So you start to see what changes in their,
their,
their posture makes when they're about to throw a punch.
Those are all things that will help.
Few.
Jujitsu is obviously great for the grinding,
physical grappling situation,
but a lot of times,
hopefully as a cop,
most of the time you're not in that situation.
You're standing at a little bit of a distance and,
or you're,
you know,
you,
you've got a little bit more time to judge.
So fight as much as you can.
Watch those law enforcement and military videos again,
see the reactions,
see the noise,
see the fear,
see the panic,
look at people's eyes,
judged them,
predict what they're gonna do.
Press pause and figure out if you will,
right or wrong,
watch horrible violence happen so that you can understand it better so that you
can handle it when the time arises.
Ya Odom.
And just kind of to to add on some of the stuff you were saying,
I would even say compete if you can,
cause a lot of times in training you can't,
especially if you're training every day or pretty often you can get into the
mindset that
I can just train casual today and if a guy taps me out,
which everyone says it doesn't matter that much.
You know,
so when you compete,
that's,
that's one of the significant things that I got bored of that I realized when I
was competing.
It's your,
your re,
your senses are heightened because everything matters.
If you get taken down,
it matters.
If you go for a submission and you don't get it,
it matters in,
in competition.
So you have that,
that mindset more so.
And you'll get used to that mindset.
And to your point,
I tell this guy's at Jujitsu,
when you're training for a competition,
no matter what we do,
just about no matter 98% of the time,
I can't get two guys in training to go as hard against each other as they're
going to end competition.
As someone,
when someone gets a grip of your GE and competition,
it is 10 times stronger than it is when you're training.
Cause if you rip,
if I get to grab your g color and you go through some effort to rip it away and
we're training,
I'm gonna let it go.
Right?
Cause I don't care if it happens in competition and I only have seven minutes to
work and get you submitted.
I'm a hang onto that thing and I'm gonna hang on to it hard.
Yeah.
And I'm not going to let go.
And so you end up with a much,
much,
much more intense,
seven minutes in a competition or three minutes in a boxing sparring match or a
or an a Moitai the intensity,
you cannot simulate the intensity in con in training that you're going to get an
a in competition and take that one step further.
When you get into a life and death struggle,
you're going to have the same level of jump to the intensity that's going to be
there.
So that's a good point as well.
Yeah,
and that kind of goes from [inaudible] as well.
I'm not even a thirdly saying competing Moitai,
but when we tie is a good one because you get cracked in your body and your legs
and you get to feel some pain.
Um,
and if you're not used to that.
Okay.
Before I even started,
when we,
today I went in,
um,
you know,
remember Terry,
so could you,
he was like,
Hey,
you know,
we,
we've trained you do two together.
It was like,
Hey,
I'm training MMA today.
Come,
let's spar with me,
my other partner doing.
And I was like,
Hey,
I don't have any striking three.
He's like,
oh,
I don't care,
you know,
Jujitsu.
So this train was me.
It's not so bright.
He punched me in the face really hard.
And that was,
you know,
and I was like,
man,
just how you were talking about this crash grenades before.
It was kind of like that.
Just the fact that I got piped in and knocked me out.
It didn't days meet in that way.
It was just the fact that Dang,
I wasn't used to this.
I didn't know he was just going to start punching me in my face.
You know,
I felt we were just going to warm up.
So that's actually the main thing that made me go into [inaudible] specifically.
So who's to get cracked?
Yeah.
Cause I was like,
Bro,
I'm not even,
I would thought it was pretty good at Jujitsu.
So I figured,
you know,
like I was,
I was solid,
you know,
but breath,
so what if I get into some thing,
you know,
outside of the gym I got cracks me in my face and I'm not used to it.
Yeah.
You know,
so men,
so I though the Muy Thai did help is when you get hit in the face,
it's like Jujitsu,
someone grinding on you and they're breathing all in your nose or they're
sweating all in your eye or whatever.
That doesn't bother you at all.
You barely notice it doesn't matter.
Right.
So the same thing with,
we tell you when you get punched in the nose and it's bleeding and you see your
own blood or whatever,
but if you're not used today,
that'd mess you up.
Yeah.
And if you notice back in the day,
like they're old UFC or whatever,
guys will get cracked in the face like three,
four times hard.
And they'll be like,
oh tap.
Oh holy cow.
You know,
cause they're just not used to it.
Nowadays guys are just,
they won't,
they won't tell him.
Yeah,
the referee got to start on it.
They're used to,
it rarely does anyone tapped in the UFC from strikes.
Very rare.
Unless they're like injured.
Even it worry d.
Yeah.
So anyway,
so,
so the point is,
so when we tie situation and specific,
because that's where you feel the most pain,
like more than boxing,
like even,
I mean you'll take brain injury for sure,
but it's not actual paint and we take it kicked in the leg and they teach you to
hide the pain and to,
to not let it affect you and go in the end and the ribs like body needs to the
ribs.
It's super painful when you get used to that.
I think that would help because like if you're in a situation,
the streets,
I'm cracks you hard in the face.
You know what's interesting about that though is that there are some people that
can,
can easily or more easily take the pain of Moy Thai or boxing.
Like it's okay with them then.
Then they,
then they can take the grind of Jujitsu and some people can take the grind of
Jujitsu all day long,
but they can never take the striking pain.
So it's,
there's just some genetic or mental situations.
But to your point,
you need to be comfortable with both those situations.
And at the very least just familiar with it.
Oh,
I,
like I said,
that first punch that I took in my face and granted it was,
I wasn't ready for him to just wail on me.
Play football too.
Yeah.
I mean,
so you've been hit,
you've been knocked out before on the field.
Right.
So it's a,
it's kind of,
if I were to try to remember it,
it was a combination of sure that physical impact,
but just the fact that this guy just punched me in my face right now,
it's almost like thanked,
this guy is punching me my base.
Right.
Not that we're going to,
yeah,
I didn't like that.
But yeah,
after a while,
it doesn't mean the hardest I ever got punched in the face was from Greg right
in the like right between my eyes.
And it was like happenstance.
He threw a real solid one.
Um,
as I went to kind of shoot eat,
who's kind of coming up off his knees kind of,
and I went to shoot like I got,
I got from off my back and then forward in shot forward and he just went,
boom.
And the,
the,
the force of me shooting forward and went boom.
And I felt it on my neck.
He was really bad,
but it was in a hard part.
Lucky but yeah,
fully.
That was a KL punch.
He just happened to be in that really hard
part.
Um,
but I had been through that before.
I train Muay Thai before and it didn't,
it didn't even slow it down.
I remember thinking that was probably the hardest punch I ever took.
And it was with the MMA glove.
It wasn't with a big boxing gloves back in the old days.
We used to just spark all full on with just MMA gloves on a regular basis.
Yes.
Stupid and don't do that folks.
Yeah.
Don't do that for the whole day.
But what I'm saying is that you were used to it.
Good.
Again,
I was used to it.
It didn't slow me down.
If that was like a situation where I took that kind of hard hit in a,
you know,
or a cop would take that kind of hard to hit and they're used to that in
training or whatever,
that's not going to slow them down.
That's not going to stun them unless it physically stuns the jars to me.
Yeah.
And that's,
you know,
even if you're trained,
that's,
that's not,
that's gonna,
that's gonna Jag.
In fact,
if you train too much and you get yourself hit too often,
you'll actually decrease your ability to withstand punishment.
So be careful about that.
You want to train enough that you're used to it.
You want to know that you can take it,
but then you don't want to overtrain add all.
Yeah.
You never get better or take,
well,
no,
let me rephrase that.
You get better at taking punches for a short period of time and then it goes,
starts to go backwards,
you know,
and unfortunately,
that's just the way the,
uh,
the body's built.
You can see as some of the older UFC fighters get older,
you know,
there's no doubt they don't have the chin that they once had.
And that's when they usually decide to hang it up if they,
you know,
if they get the right counsel from people.
But nowadays people are sparring a lot less and they're trying to not take all
that punishment because everyone realizes that you have a,
you have a limited number of hits you can take to the,
to the head and then it starts to go backwards.
And it's just,
you know,
a lot of this information is coming from the,
the soldiers overseas,
the marines overseas that have taken concussions and IED strikes and they're
realizing that that is a permanent,
you know,
downgrade of their systems and they,
they,
you know,
so they,
that's where a lot of this information came from about football,
concussion stuff in football.
A lot of that is coming from the,
the ids that our soldiers and marines have taken overseas and they've realized
that this traumatic trauma,
traumatic brain injury is problematic.
And so we need to,
we need to watch out for it.
So yeah,
especially if you're being a cop and you gotta be alert.
But that's why the,
and that's why I like the Muy Thai.
That's why I personally,
I did.
Yeah.
Because it was a lot of like clenching needs and those,
if you were,
if,
if you've never done it,
you would think they'd been punched in the nose square in the nose real hard
would be probably one of the more painful things,
but it wasn't compared to the ribs and the legs,
man.
So if you're kind of used to just taking impacts in pain,
yeah.
You just,
you just,
and not to mention the physical part,
but just mentally,
they're like,
when that,
when that comes about,
you can just,
just
keep on keeping on now.
Yeah.
Cause you're used to it from a inoculate.
Inoculate yourself and not killing.
Okay.
Next question.
Doco I have three little girls and I'm really intrigued by Brazilian Jujitsu.
What form of martial art would you put your kids in?
That's an easy one.
Yeah.
Uh,
put your kids into Jujitsu.
Do it immediately.
Uh,
we kind of covered this,
the last podcast and that is the fact that
if you got a teacher gets up,
don't get in a street fight,
don't get into a fight in the playground.
If someone wants to fight you runaway,
and that's what they should do.
And you know,
later when they start to become mature enough to make real decisions that should
guide them.
And occasionally as a man,
you may have to stand your ground and fight and that's understandable.
But as a little kid who might be getting picked on by bigger kids,
Hey,
oh,
somebody gets in your face,
runaway.
If you really think you're gonna get hurt,
So you have that self defense mechanism already.
What you don't have and what you are not born with is when that bully grabs you
and pulls you to the ground or grabs you and holds onto you and won't let you
leave.
That is when you need to know how to grapple.
And Jujitsu is what teaches you how to grapple.
So eventually,
like you just said,
you do want your kids to spar a little bit.
You do want your kids to know how to throw some good combinations?
They,
right.
I mean they should know how to do that.
Uh,
in your,
in the,
actually the other night I was working with Dean and we were working with a
couple people and just go,
he was going over some basic self defense and there are some legit basic self
defense moves.
Did people should know,
you know,
someone bear hugs,
you,
someone had box you.
Now we don't think about them at the high level of Jujitsu because we,
we welcome someone had locking us.
We welcome that stuff because we're so used to it.
It says we have an advantage when we get there.
But to a kid you get thrown into a headlock.
Uh,
first street fight I ever got out of the first guy,
can't call it a street fight.
The first time ever got into a fight wasn't,
you know,
like fourth or fifth grade.
And this kid who was definitely way stronger than me,
grabbed me in a headlock,
was holding me on the ground and punched me in the head and I did,
couldn't do anything.
And you know,
it got broken up after 20 seconds by the principal.
But Oh,
it's okay.
You don't okay that,
that wasn't cool.
So what you want your kid,
cause if that kid would have tried to attack me when I was standing up,
I can just run away from him.
But once he grabbed a hold of me,
all of a sudden I can't do anything.
So that's why Jujitsu is the first thing you want to learn.
It's also,
as I said last time,
it's the most technical thing.
It,
there's the most to learn.
It's a never ending,
uh,
knowledge quest.
So you want to get on that quest as early as possible.
Now on top of that,
and what's really good about Jujitsu,
and again,
this is something that I've talked about before,
but when you talk about traditional martial arts and you imagine,
you know a traditional martial arts dojo where people in plain white ghees are
standing in a very clean and Spartan facility with Samurai swords Hain on the
wall and they're bowing to the Sensei,
that implies a certain amount of knowledge will be passed and a certain amount
of etiquette will be passed.
And the etiquette and the knowledge that we passed will be toughness and
confidence and humility.
And as a matter of fact,
if you go to a traditional martial arts school and you bring your kid in there
and you say,
I want my kid to train,
what will he get out of it?
One of the things that are going to say is he's going to learn to be confident
or she's going to learn humility and they will teach them that verbally.
It will be a lesson,
it will be a
book,
almost a book lesson on this is humility and this is confidence and hold your
head high.
Jujitsu teaches those things.
Not Theoretically,
but for real.
Because in Jujitsu you will get humbled.
You will get humbled by a peer,
someone that's smaller than you by someone that's weaker than you.
They will submit you,
they will hold you down and you won't be able to do anything about it.
And that is humility.
And that is where you learn humility and Jujitsu.
And same thing with confidence.
You know,
you will learn as you get better at Jujitsu that hey,
I know something and I know I can handle myself in bad situations.
So it truly teaches humility and confidence.
Not Theoretically,
but in a very practical sense,
you know.
So get your kids down to the Jujitsu school,
get them enrolled.
And you know,
we,
we w we did a podcast where we talked about how to find a good Jujitsu school.
So find a good reputable place and get your kids down there.
And you know what,
when you bring your kids in to start Jujitsu,
get your Dang self on the mat too.
Cause you got to know it and it's,
everybody should know.
Yeah,
the end,
except for bullies and evil people,
they should be banned from Jujitsu cause it's too powerful.
Wait two months.
Another element that,
um,
that you might not think of right off the bat,
but,
um,
the fact that you'll meet friends cause [inaudible] for whatever reason.
I mean it just might be the in general,
but
when you go to like the Jujitsu,
so you go on the mats,
it's not like how you're saying like a traditional martial arts school where
you're like,
don't talk bow,
be rigid.
Stand like this while the Sensei's talking say yes sir.
No Sir.
It's,
it's really,
I mean in my experience that I've been to a lot,
especially here in southern California there,
that's where most of them are.
It's real.
Even though the more rigid ones are casual,
casual before class,
you can talk even during class,
as long as you're not talking while the instructor's,
yeah.
Do you,
do you do that in a school?
You wouldn't do that anywhere.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
but you know what,
you're practicing moves.
It's,
it's,
um,
of course he don't want to deviate too much from the lesson.
But it,
it's just more social.
And so you talk after class and you'll find that,
that the atmosphere is really conducive to gravitating towards people that,
that have the same interests.
Have you even outside of Jujitsu and kids,
especially men,
because usually the teachers are way more lenient with kids when they're running
around and you know,
you're telling them,
go do this move and they might be talking a little bit about something or
whatever.
If they're having fun,
which it is very fun.
Um,
they're just going to want to do it some more.
And then my daughter's two and we found a place that,
that could facilitate a two year old situation and she would always look forward
to it because they,
she just think it's just one big display house,
the rough housing the whole time.
It's the ultimate dream for a kid.
I'll room with padded floors and padded walls and you can grab the clothes and
rough house all you want people to the ground.
Yeah.
You're not going to get punched or kicked or,
you know.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
yeah.
So there is a,
a good community aspect to Jujitsu.
Yes,
very much so.
Which echo likes very much so.
Sometimes I don't even want to roll.
I just want to come and talk.
So sometimes that's often the situation with that Jocko Willink.
So basically being a new leader,
overcoming friction in the new organization,
that's this.
That's what this guy is.
He's,
you know,
he's a new leader.
Overcoming friction in an organization.
Any penetrating insight.
Yeah,
and I think what's important here is this is he's not a new leader like newly
commissioned leaders stepping up in the ranks.
He's a new in a new organization.
So he's stepping into a new organization leader.
Yes,
the new leader in a new situation.
Gotcha.
We've kind of talked about stepping up from within the organization.
How do you go in and step into a new organization?
Now I'm going to look at this from a perspective of of like a normal transition
into a leadership position and a new job or something like that.
Not a hostile takeover situation.
Maybe we can address that on a later time,
but not a situation where,
hey,
they fired this guy.
He had a bad reputation.
The things are going wrong,
you're going to step in and change it because that that would take a different
leadership approach.
Then the one that I,
that I would take and that I have taken where you're stepping into a situation
where things are going okay and you put your coming in and you've got some goals
and there's so you're taking over leadership position.
It happens all the time.
Um,
so a couple of things about this.
First of all,
you step into a new leadership role.
You got to talk to people,
but you mostly got to listen.
You've got to find out why they're doing things the way they are.
Because a lot of times there might be reasons for the way things are happening
that you don't understand or that aren't really particularly evident.
So you really want to not make the judgements because you're bringing your own
experience and you've done this a thousand times and that's why you're the new
leader and that's why they put you in here.
You got to set that aside and say,
okay,
explain to me why this process is in place,
or where did this process come from?
Or what does this process trying to prevent?
So that way you're getting smarter and you're learning and you're not being,
you're not imposing your ideas,
which you don't have any background for.
You don't,
you know,
you may have been a leadership in a different company or a different unit before
and you think you know,
but you don't know.
So be humble and check yourself.
Um,
you got to be friendly to people,
but at the same time you gotta be reserved.
Now this is,
this is tricky because you are trying to build relationships.
You absolutely are trying to build relationships.
That's what life is.
That's what business is.
That's what war is.
That's what everything is about.
Building relationships with these other humans.
So you want to be friendly to people,
but at the same time,
from a leadership perspective,
you can't just come in and be Mr Nice guy and best friends with everybody.
That's not going to work out for you for a couple reasons.
Number one,
you don't know the,
the face that people are going to present you out of the gate is not necessarily
the true face of that person.
So you may check in your first day and this guy,
hey,
it's great to meet you.
So good to have you on board,
heard a lot about you and you go,
wow,
this guys,
and he's ticked,
starts giving you some background information about things that are going.
And by the way,
we got a couple of things that are a little messed up,
you know,
and I can point him out to you,
but that guy might be working his agenda.
So you Ganna be cautious as you go in.
Um,
and the other piece of that is it is much easier to reel back in slack or sorry,
it's much easier to give out that friendship later than it is if you go
overboard and you become everyone's best friend and now you got to cut it off
and all of a sudden you become a jerk.
So it's much easier to,
to give out the slack when you want to later than it is to give out a bunch of
slack and then try and reel it back in and be a jerk.
And that makes it hard for both parties.
That's why in that case,
yeah,
like what?
It's going to be really hard.
The only reason you're pulling back the friendship thing is because it started
going sideways and that makes it even harder.
It's a nightmare.
Uh,
got to watch out for the gossip because everyone's going to want to whisper in
your ear the things about the things about the people and this and that.
So you gotta be careful,
nod your head,
take it,
be onboard,
but take it with a grain of salt.
Definitely don't encourage it yet.
And that can be a hard part for certain types of people will say,
because let's face it,
man,
that can be some interesting stuff.
There can be some knowledge to be gained there,
but you just have to be careful.
You want to hear some insights.
Right.
But be careful when the insights crossover into gossip.
Yeah.
And be careful that the insights are coming from people that might have agendas.
In fact,
they are coming from people that have agendas because everybody has agendas and
maybe the person has a positive agenda,
which is to improve the company or improve the unit or improve the team,
but they also might have a agenda of improving their own station in life.
So you have to be careful of that.
They are watching you,
they are watching you.
When you come in to take over,
So act accordingly.
Think about the fact that they are watching you.
Like I said,
use caution and forming these new relationships.
You got to find out who's who.
You want to establish things.
But again,
you got to watch out because people might not necessarily be who they make
themselves out to be in the beginning.
So this is kind of becoming a little bit of a chorus.
When I talk about leading,
be humble,
listen,
learn,
move methodically.
When it does come time to make change in a new situation,
most of the time I would say do it incrementally.
Do smaller changes after you've assessed fully and you've got people,
a p got people's opinions and you've expressed and socialized your ideas so
you're not trying to roll in there and change the world again.
Now if we go into a hostel turnover situation or there's someone's been fired
for cause or that's a different situation,
but for a normal transition into a new job,
be humble,
listen,
learn and lead that part where you're,
you're talking about,
find out why they're doing the things that the way they are and stuff like that.
Um,
that part can be depending on certain people's personality.
Like if you're coming in as the new guy and you and you ask,
start asking,
hey,
why do you guys do it like this?
If you come off with the wrong tone,
sometimes it'll sound like that.
You're questioning.
Oh,
for sure.
I remember when I worked at the nightclub,
we had a new manager,
um,
and
his name was Joel.
He,
uh,
he,
he came in and he was strangely,
he was this whole list personified.
He came in,
he was really friendly but really reserved.
But the one thing he did cut it to address what,
what else?
We did a good chair.
Really good job.
Yeah.
Except as,
no,
nothing I'm saying is an example of how he
clarified that.
He's not questioning the way we're doing stuff.
He's not saying,
hey,
where are you doing it like that because this way sucks.
It didn't have that tone.
But he came to me and I saw him do it to the other guy where he,
he came in and said,
hey,
I'm,
I'm going to be asking a lot of questions cause obviously I'm new here,
you know,
just so I can understand and,
and,
and get on board with what you're doing so it can be ultimately what we're
doing.
That's what he said.
He said it in a little bit different way obviously.
But um,
that's what he said and that right away.
So no matter what the question he asked,
it was almost like,
shoot,
I want to tell this guy how it's working.
You know,
cause he's,
he's,
he's on my team automatically.
He told me that and he was on my team.
So I think if that can be clarified that you're not like questioning me because
it seems like,
you know,
I want to make it seem like,
um,
you know,
I know a better way right off the bat.
You don't want that tone,
you know,
I know just from a on the receiving end,
I don't want that.
Tell him nope.
Cause I'm going to be all,
yeah.
So anyway,
yes,
yes.
In the last thing I kind of had written down here was,
um,
enjoy it.
It's,
it's,
it's awesome stepping into a new leadership position and it's challenging to do
what you just talked about,
to transition people in to your leadership realm and to do it in a subtle way
that brings them on board with a positive attitude.
So enjoy that challenge.
Yeah.
Cause it's,
it's pretty fun.
It's challenging and most importantly it's rewarding.
Yeah.
Next question,
Jah.
Cool.
How do you learn slash practice detachment in realtime
detachment?
So this is something
that I have talked about a lot and it is definitely a very important part of
leadership and it's a very important part
of
of finding it,
finding your way successfully through life.
It's an important part of navigation of,
of the world.
So,
and if,
if you haven't heard me talk about this,
this is the idea that you are not caught up in the emotions and the chaos and
the,
and the tactical firefight that's happening.
You detach so you can make good judgments about things.
So how do you do it?
How do you learn it and how do you practice it?
Step number one
is awareness.
Awareness
of yourself.
So you start asking yourself,
wait,
how am I being perceived right now?
If you can just occasionally start asking yourself,
How is echo seeing me right now?
So all of a sudden you've,
you started to take other people's perspective,
which is,
it's a good start because it's not your own.
And the goal is to,
is to get outside of your own perspective and see yourself from some kind of a
distance.
So you start asking yourself,
how am I being perceived?
And then start trying to watch yourself like what do I look like right now?
Am I caught inside that madness?
And once you start to do that,
that's going to be like your,
that's going to be your little tool that you're gonna use is getting outside and
just watching yourself and saying,
okay,
I am aware of what I'm doing right now.
I am aware of what I am doing right now.
And then what you want to do is you want to set some kind of alerts because you
don't walk around.
I don't walk around detached from myself all the time.
I'm not,
I mean,
otherwise you would have no joy and you would have no,
you'd have no pain,
you'd have no emotions because you'd be detached from it.
So you don't walk.
I don't walk around just detached all the time,
but I do have some alerts,
some little red flags,
and we'll triggers.
That happened in my mind that when I feel them,
I know,
okay,
you're starting to go too far and you're losing
the perception of yourself.
What's your,
your trigger there?
A couple of them.
Number one is like some strong emotion like anger,
you know,
anger.
You start,
if you start clenching your fist or you start raising your voice,
that should be a warning.
Okay?
You are not thinking clearly right now.
Detached from this.
Get away from these emotions.
Um,
some kind of chaos.
I like chaos happening and you're in it.
Whether it's in a supermarket,
whether it's,
you know,
something bad,
something violent,
something mob.
If you're getting in that situation,
you start feeling that.
Detach yourself from it cause you can get caught up in it's any overwhelming
excitement will be it.
Now here's a good red flag.
Here's a good red flag.
Good alert is the 27th time you bang your head against the wall attacking a
problem,
whatever that problem is.
You know,
and I actually made this joke the other day,
a Jujitsu because we're talking about passing someone's guard and people will
try and try and try one way,
one way,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
And I'm like,
listen,
after your 27th attempt to pass someone's guard,
same way,
go ahead and try another way.
So this happens a lot where if you find yourself beating your head against the
wall after the 27th time,
go ahead and let that be a little alert that you need to detach.
You need to get,
cause there's some reason that you're doing this.
Yeah,
maybe it's an emotional reason.
Maybe it's just you're too close to the problem.
Maybe it's that the problem has a hold of you and you don't recognize it.
But let that be in the alert trigger that tells you,
hey buddy,
detach.
Take a look around and see if there's another way.
Now another huge thing that requires detachment.
Okay,
is your ego,
your big,
nasty,
powerful ego.
It's one of the biggest things that you have to utilize the attachment to
overcome.
And let me tell you some of the things that will warn you that your ego is now
in the game.
And when your ego's in the game,
when your ego is in the game and it,
it will very easily when it will beat you.
So when you're feeling
jealousy,
likely that's going to be your ego and actually hurts somebody or somebody on
Twitter.
He hit me with this the other day and it was something along the lines of,
uh,
if you're feeling jealous,
instead of saying,
I'm jealous of this person,
say what can I learn from this person?
Wow.
Great statement.
Right?
Because that's when you set your ego.
That's when you detach from your ego and you say,
okay,
I'm not going to be jealous of this person.
They can teach me something.
Uh,
when you start feeling frustrated,
when you first start feeling disgust or anger,
where is that emotion coming from?
Very high likelihood.
It's coming from your ego.
So you need to put that ego in to check.
Do you think that's the hardest one,
do you think?
Oh yeah.
Although,
yeah,
they can all be pretty hard.
I mean,
because you know,
w w when you get emotional about the relationship,
yeah.
I mean that's not always your ego.
That can be your ego,
especially if there's another person involved.
Right.
But a lot of times that's not your ego.
That's,
that's your emotion that's hurting and causing problems.
Um,
but yeah,
the ego,
I actually find the ego because it's so clear.
It's so clear that you're just being an idiot with your ego.
I always go,
God,
I'm stupid.
Why am I doing this?
Yeah.
Uh,
and I think it,
he's usually pretty good.
I think the ones that are harder or a little bit a bit more subtle,
you know?
Yeah.
And that's Kinda what it mean because the ego is like,
that's how powerful it is because it,
any extreme situation or Eric extreme example,
any one of these,
like if you get really angry,
it's easy to see.
I lost pay temporary right there and you shouldn't have done that,
shouldn't have yelled at,
you know,
whatever.
Or if your ego's prevalent in this really,
um,
just to,
in a real strong way.
It's obvious.
Of course it's not,
but the Eagle,
I feel like it's like that subtlety of it makes it hard.
Yeah.
Because you know,
that last part of the,
it's like if you want to remove your ego,
it's,
it's almost like a bucket of sand where you got to get the last corner of your
ego out for it to work.
Otherwise,
we eagle still in the game.
It was always in the game.
And,
and I don't encourage people to,
I'm not like the boot of it says completely eliminate your ego because your ego
is what's driving you in many cases to perform well,
to win.
There's nothing wrong with that,
you know,
and if you,
uh,
but the part of the Ayn rand in the end of what's that book anyways,
she's like,
ego is this,
God blessed the ego.
You know,
this yeah.
Uh,
in,
it's pretty powerful because that's what drives you.
That's the individual effort.
The problem is there's a dichotomy of everything and sometimes your ego will get
the best of you and that's what you need to watch out for.
And that's when you got to learn to detach from it.
Yeah.
So it's like each situation you have a certain sized cup that can only hold so
much ego to get it done and then any even one drop,
it's going to jam you up when you're,
if you're one drop overflowing,
you know?
And you could make bad decisions with your ego if you let it get in the way.
Yeah man.
And that's the hard thing because B and I think that's probably the reason
because you need your ego to,
to kind of function,
to get tasks done and excel and all this stuff.
So you have to basically find that fine line that you have to get rid of,
you know,
the,
at what point do you get rid of enough ego to still having enough you go to get
the task done,
you know,
so the dichotomy.
Yeah.
Sometimes you don't realize it.
Um,
not that I ever have that problem.
Nothing like that.
I'm just saying it seems like we are that problem,
unfortunately.
Okay.
Jocko,
what do you think of people in leadership roles who,
cause I see it in coaching guys either totally use it or are totally against it.
So swearing,
cussing,
using foul language.
Uh,
I think this is pretty straight forward question.
I can tell you that by no means
am I a saint and,
and you know,
I was in the seal teams for 20 years.
And
when you've heard the term swear like a sailor,
there's actually a level beyond that and that's swearing like a seal.
And so I,
I've,
you know,
there's times in the seal teams where literally,
every single word in a sentence would be,
you know,
a swear word.
Uh,
and,
and that's something that when I go back and brief the brief,
the seal teams right now on something,
I go almost right back into that mode.
You know,
not,
not quite as bad as I would probably was at the high point of my career where I
was well rehearsed and well trained at foul language.
But,
uh,
but hey,
here's the deal on a forum like this where we're on a podcast where,
you know,
many,
many people listen to this,
including kids and my kids.
And,
um,
I try and utilize better language now.
And I'll tell you what,
I actually had a point where I sort of said to myself,
me,
I'm not going to do that.
And I heard a podcast,
what,
you're not going to do?
What?
I'm not going to square.
I'll blocks.
I'm not,
I'm not going to be an,
I'm not just going to square the whole time and a podcast.
And this actually happened because I heard a podcast,
I listened to a podcast where it was actually,
it was a conversation,
you know,
normal podcast.
There's a conversation going on between two people.
And they were swearing so much that I just said to myself,
man,
this sounds ridiculous.
It just sounded,
it sounded completely ridiculous.
And I just decided after,
and this was before we started our prior,
this was,
you know,
maybe like two years ago.
I mean,
it was a long time ago.
I heard this podcast and I just said to myself,
these people sound stupid with so much swearing and um,
and it wasn't it.
The thing is like,
you listen to Joe Rogan or like a comedic podcast and they're swearing and,
and some people,
like for instance,
Joe Rogan,
he swears he does it at the right time and it has comedic impact.
Word has value when he does it.
So,
so that's understandable.
But I've heard people that they just,
it's,
it's just,
it doesn't,
it ends up having no impact other than just to make you say,
this person is not very smart.
Right.
So with that,
you know,
I just tried to keep it clean.
Um,
but actually it's not even almost like I don't consciously sit there and try and
keep it clean,
but,
uh,
you know,
I try and keep it clean.
Is that kind of like,
you know,
people,
uh,
most of us have this little,
the problem,
but what would they like,
like,
you know,
very similar,
like,
oh,
it just did.
It's still kinda like that.
Yeah,
it is.
It's the same thing where when you hear someone saying like,
like,
like it,
as soon as you,
you might not even recognize it at first because we're used to hearing it.
Yeah.
But if you pick up on it and you're listening to a podcast and you start to hear
someone do that,
it's the same thing.
You just say,
wow,
this person really sounds stupid and they might be smart,
but this person sounds really stupid and I'm not going to sound like that.
So that's pretty much where,
uh,
where my opinion comes from and why.
And you know what,
I have had a couple people hit me up and say,
you know,
hey,
this is the only podcast that I listened to that my kids can listen to.
And that's,
that's kind of cool.
You know,
I,
I appreciate that.
It's,
it's pretty,
um,
it's pretty humbling to hear that people are sitting there listening to podcasts
where their kids,
yeah.
And I guess humbling is the wrong word,
which somebody hit me up on Twitter.
It's an honor.
It's an honor that doesn't feel like I deserve,
but it's an honor to hear somebody sitting around and say,
Oh,
you know,
I listened to his podcast with my daughter,
or I listened to your podcast with my son,
and it's so many good lessons to learn.
And that that feels pretty good.
Yeah.
And so if I was to throw that out the window so that I could drop some f bombs,
yeah.
It doesn't really seem worth it because what kind of,
uh,
what kind of a linguistic command do I have?
If the only way I can get my point across is by,
is by using foul language.
You know,
and the funny thing is too,
is,
well,
I used to go,
you know,
when I was in the seal teams,
I would go and literally,
like I said,
my,
I would have whole sentence constructions that would be nothing but f bombs.
Right.
And I would come home and in front of my six,
six year old kid or whatever,
I never swore in front of my kids.
And people would be kind of surprised.
Like if I had a seal buddy over and they'd hear me talk in my house and they'd
say,
how do you even do that?
How do you,
and I don't know why,
I've just been able to do it.
So that was another thing.
You know,
these podcasts,
when you go on the interwebs,
they're there for,
I hate to say it,
but they're there for ever.
And you can take them down.
But these are going to be,
these are out there.
So if you,
if you want to be represented that way for the rest of your life,
then you gotta be a little bit careful about what you're saying.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
cause I,
I kinda like sweat.
No,
I don't like to swear,
but I like when people swear and stuff,
I think it's,
but just like how you were saying,
like for example,
Joe Rogan,
like he'll swear and sometimes they'll swear a lot,
but it's perfect.
It's funny when it needs to be funny.
It emphasizes,
you know,
a certain emotion when it needs to.
It's,
it's perfect.
And that's kind of the reason why I like it because sometimes it can be really
funny.
It can be fun to do.
Um,
but overall there's a certain kind of,
you can't help but kind of respect someone who doesn't like,
okay,
use the word like all the time where that doesn't say I'm all the time or who
doesn't say you know,
all the time or no I'm saying or whatever.
Um,
and,
and can can control that.
And I think swearing is yet another one of those things that some people,
it's more of a weakness where they kind of,
they didn't know how to use it.
They just swear it cause they swore,
they knew my parents were.
So I swear who cares kind of thing.
And on top of that,
you do have to consider who you're talking to.
And in a podcast situation you're essentially talking to everybody regardless of
the role you,
you were trying to talk to who you think or want your audience to be.
It's everyone and anyone who presses the button,
it's going to be listening.
So if you don't care how you come off and then good,
then that's,
that's great.
But I think you do have more of a control on how you come off,
when you can control.
How much you swear,
don't swear.
Well,
I haven't had anybody,
you know,
hit me up on Twitter and say,
hey,
you really need to swear him in the water.
Right.
It doesn't happen.
No one said,
hey,
you need to say Amore or they need to say like more people don't need to hear
that.
They accept it because it's there.
And I'll tell you a funny,
the first time I took my,
used to take my son out occasionally to various seal training sites,
you know,
in order to inoculate him to violence and firearms and machine guns and war
and uh,
yes,
you've all people can all call child services on me.
Uh,
but it was funny the first time,
you know,
he watched a SQL platoon do some event and I think it was at,
uh,
at,
urban training facility and they got done and I was debriefing them and you
know,
this is my son who had never heard me swear and who kind of use at that age
where,
you know,
less swearing ward was like,
worst thing ever.
And He,
you know,
he was standing there and I debrief these guys and I,
I debrief them in the proper seal technique and I got done.
He had a look on his face that said,
wow,
this guy is a little different than what I knew.
He was pretty shocked and it was a,
he was a pretty funny scenario.
So you know how you say you don't swear in front of your kids?
Um,
why is that?
Because you don't want them to swear or were,
and
there is,
you know,
if you ever see a in an,
I do now that my daughters are a little older,
I'll drop some swear words in them in occasionally for impact or for humor,
you know,
or for whatever.
So,
so I will do it.
But if you ever see a,
a young girl swearing it,
you see a young boy,
you know,
it very much seems disrespectful in my opinion.
So I don't want my kids to be running around with a foul mouth.
Now,
I took my son and a couple of his buddies went a little surf trip and they were
sleeping in a tent outside of,
and I was in the,
I was in the camper and I woke up at when I normally wake up and they were what?
They were up early to go surfing as well,
but I was standing outside their tent and I was pretty impressed with the wide
array of foul language that they produced.
And that's kind of the thing too,
right?
So it doesn't,
if you'd never swear to your kids,
it's not like you have protected them for swearing.
So that's,
that's my point is that after I stood out there for awhile and I listened to
them and then I said something along the lines of,
Hey,
are you guys done?
I know you ready to go surfing.
And my son says,
how long have you been out there?
That in?
And I swore back at him,
I swore back at him and said,
I've been out here long.
And then they kind of remained quiet for a second and then they started
laughing.
I said,
all right boys,
let's go.
So I'm not a goody two shoes.
I understand.
And you know,
we talked about pat and patents SRE incessantly amongst the troops and then when
he'd get in front of the politicians he would not,
and I guess I would hope to behave that way.
And I used to do that too.
I used to go there was when we got back from Ramadi,
I had to go and brief the secretary of the navy.
I had to go brief the congressional joint caucus.
I mean I had to go and brief some high level governmental officials and whatnot
and I would just walk in there and not,
well obviously you're not going to swear in front of them.
So I think that's another,
another situation where you've got to know and understand when to swear in one
when not to swear.
And I just,
hopefully I'm making the right decisions.
And like I said,
no one has,
uh,
no one has hit me up and said,
you really need to use more foul language.
And you know,
there's times where we've,
you know,
we've used foul language on the PR on the podcast because hey,
it's a reality.
It's a reality of Vietnam.
It's a reality of all wars.
So to exclude it,
like it doesn't exist is not what I'm trying to do here.
And that's kind of a big,
in my opinion,
a big deal.
When someone you can tell they're,
they're actively pursuing,
not swearing where in any kind of,
especially in casual conversation where they were about to say something.
And then the um,
then the youth like,
I dunno sugar,
I don't Dunno,
you know,
those re obvious replacement where it's,
and there's nothing wrong with it,
but it does kind of kind of make you think,
oh wait,
like we,
so we can't just be ourselves right now.
Like we,
I don't know.
It feels like you may not feel fake or relate to it.
Yeah.
You know what's interesting is you've seen full metal jacket and just an amazing
movie about the Marine Corps and the whole,
the whole,
the whole first 45 minutes is bootcamp and it's played
by Lee.
Ramy ethic is his name and he does.
He was a real jewel instructor.
And so he just nails it.
And I remember when my son was six or seven years old,
I go and I thought to myself,
I'll,
I'll play him some of this movie.
We,
I'll just find some parts that don't have any foul language.
There are no parts.
The whole thing is just completely over the top and it's awesome.
Um,
so,
so there's definitely a time and a place for it.
And the other thing is,
for me,
honestly,
it's,
you know,
how was,
I'm always trying to do better at stuff.
There's a challenge be in trying to find words that are going to have impact
without just going right to the easy button on them on the big F bomb cause
that's going to have impact.
But if that's what you need to use,
then it's just a little easy out that I don't want to take it every single time
it presents itself and it'll tell you when I get,
there's been a couple times with my kids where they've stepped over the line or
there's something out of line and when I,
I went to have sworn at them,
it was like I slapped him in the face because it was having that much impact.
Whereas if I was just throwing around all the time,
it's taken away the impact of,
right,
right.
Yeah.
So strategically it's strategic swearing patent apparently with,
um,
from what I read,
he,
when he'd get people fired up,
he'd do that on purpose.
Oh.
And then like even just in normal conversation,
he didn't really swear that much.
That's one of the things.
So he used it as a,
as a specific tool,
you know,
to get certain things done.
As far as influence goes.
Yeah.
I can't believe we've talked for 10 minutes about swearing.
That's what it needed to be talking about.
Hey,
we got to ask the question.
I think we've got time for one more.
Okay,
last question,
Jocko.
What techniques do you use to deal with situational stress from battlefield to
boardroom?
Well,
first of all,
and I don't mean to minimize the stress that people face,
but imagine a pageant.
What Eugene Sledge that we talked about tonight.
Imagine what he went through on Pellalou in the tens of thousands of marines
that's suffered debt,
unimaginable horror.
Any imagine Hackworth who we talked about here,
who wrote about face assaulting enemy positions in Korea and he was wounded over
and over again.
All in the line.
It's still went back for more.
And then you've got Alan Seeger,
the poet
who in World War One when over the top,
over and over again to make his rendezvous with death.
And there's been thousands and hundreds of thousands,
millions of that have been in very stressful situations and faith,
evil and phase death much worse than the situation
I'm in.
Or a urine that we might consider stressful.
And I even did this when I was overseas,
when I was on deployment,
when I was a combat leader,
I was feeling stress.
And you know what?
We took casualties and it was awful and it was heartbreaking,
but there were other soldiers and warriors throughout time that had been in much
worse situations,
Gettysburg or Vicksburg or the battle,
the bowl
and and all those horrible situations.
They prove really that humans can withstand almost,
almost unimaginable stress,
which meant to me that I could too.
And you can and,
and the first step for me is doing that,
taking that look to gain some perspective.
And then in order to gain perspective,
you've got to do something that we already talked about.
You've got to detach.
You've got to detach from the problems or the stress that you're experiencing
so that you can get that perspective of them.
Now
there's a couple different types of stress.
Now,
if it's something that you can control that's causing you stress,
well why aren't you getting control of it?
Generally it's a lack of discipline.
So you got to have the discipline to grab control and make it happen.
And when I say you need discipline for that,
what that means is these stresses that you're avoiding,
they're not going to go away.
If you avoid them.
So take the discipline and to face the stressful situation,
get ahead of it.
Don't be afraid of it.
Now there's also stress that's caused by things that you cannot control.
And if you remember talking earlier about artillery and how horrible that was,
and what made it so horrible was that there's no control over.
So if you can't control something and you can't get control of it,
you have to at least embrace what you can.
And I'm not saying you're going to embrace artillery shelling,
but I'll tell you what,
when it comes to things artillery or for us in Ramadi was iads and we could do
everything we could do to mitigate that risk.
But eventually there's only so much you can do and you cannot completely
eliminate it,
but you can't control it.
So why you going to worry about it?
Why you gonna stress about it?
If there's something that is completely beyond your control,
you cannot.
You've got to detach from it and not let yourself get stressed about it.
And on top of that,
if it's something that you can't control,
how can you look at it in a different light?
How can you see it in a way that you could actually take advantage of it?
How can you take
that stress and make it into some kind of ally?
You know,
the,
the chaos of combat is something that I couldn't control,
but I had to embrace it so I could try and figure out how to take advantage of
it.
So when it comes to stress,
don't fight it,
turn it on itself and use it.
Use it.
Use it to make yourself sharper and more alert and use it to make yourself think
more and learn more and get better and use that stress
as a catalyst to make yourself better.
And I think that's all we've got for tonight.
So thanks to everybody for tuning in and listening to us.
Thanks for the feedback through the interwebs to me,
um,
at Jocko Willink and to echo who is at echo,
Charles,
thanks for leaving reviews of the podcast and the book on iTunes and on Amazon
because those are very helpful.
And most of all,
thanks to everybody for getting out there and getting after it.
So until next time,
this is Jocko and echo
out.